qualité de président du jury du prix de
thèse j'ai le plaisir de vous présenter
thomas michalak qui a obtenu ce prix en
[Musique]
ce travail a pour objectif d'une part de
souligner la singularité du juge
politique dans l'ordre juridique
français et d'autre part de dévoiler
toute la délicatesse pour un corps
politique investi d'une fonction
juridictionnelle à se comporter comme un
tribunal ordinaire cette étude intéresse
tout particulièrement d'institutions
sénatoriales et le bicamérisme son
intitulé renvoie aux expériences
judiciaire de la cour des pères qui
jugea une vingtaine d'affaires et du
senate la troisième république qui fut
dirigé à six occasions en cour de
justice ce sont les manifestations les
plus marquantes de la participation
d'une assemblée parlementaire à la
reddition de la justice toutefois
ouvrage ne se limite pas à l'examen de
la métamorphose un organe législatif en
tribunal il s'intéresse également aux
systèmes d haute cour dans sa globalité
pour faire ressortir les subtilités d'un
jugement politique l'analyse du discours
évolutif sur les autres courts un
discours prôné par la doctrine
publiciste constitutionnaliste mais un
discours comprenant également les
opinions des jurés ou dix juges
parlementaires cette analyse a permis de
planter des balises dans l'histoire de
la justice politique française elle
révèle surtout les limites atteintes par
les assemblées parlementaires dans leur
fonction de juge pénal dès la révolution
on a cherché à créer une haute
juridiction a vocation pérenne est
inscrite dans l'ordre constitutionnel
que tout devait distinguer d'un tribunal
d'exception pourtant la tâche s'est vite
révélée ardue si ce n'est impossible
obtenir un juge politique indépendant et
impartial relever de la gageure les
infractions à la séparation des pouvoirs
et à la spécialisation fonctionnelle des
organes ont constitué des obstacles
insurmontables à la reddition d'une
telle justice à cet ensemble de
considérations un crédite ainsi la thèse
de l'échec celle d'un paradigme est
réalisable consiste en la présence d'un
juge politique au pouvoir singulier dans
l'ordre juridique
[Musique]